à kiev on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
cyril payen cyril bonsoir où en
sommes-nous à kiev
écoutez nous avons passé la journée sur
le front du nord ouest un à
pizza 20 km du centre de kiev et je peux
vous dire que depuis 48 heures eh bien
le scénario est complètement différent
il y a les forces spéciales
l'ukrainienne qui commence à acheminer
des blindés également alors qu'il y à un
flux incessant de de réfugiés de
familles entières qui désespérément
tentent de fuir les combats et une
intensification très impressionnante ce
matin des combats en débit hand et
hiboux le disiez des annonces de moscou
de corridors humanitaires ou de
cessez-le-feu cela n'est pas arrivé ce
matin et toute la journée puisque nous
avons été à irbine avec georgia tech
sous les bombardements et les tirs
d'artillerie en permanence toute la
journée dont tout cela était un effet
d'annoncé qui n'essaie pas du tout
concrétiser sur le terrain et il est
vrai pour conclure ce soir on sent bien
résolument que le rouleau compresseur de
le principe of tribe sport facile russe
pardon et bien ce se mobilise vers la
capitale et qu'on s'attend évidemment à
temps un siège évident de l'entière de
l'entièreté de la capitale ukrainienne
kiev merci beaucoup s'ils ne tiennent
pas bien donc envoyé spécial avec
georgia ce bec à kiev